hello everybody
what strikes me about many of your
characters up until nocturnal animals is
that they are often boys or men coming
to grips with unacceptable circumstances
and facing choices i'm wondering if as
you're reading the script as you're
preparing for the role do you see that
moment when they can go from
one thing to another do you pinpoint
that beat and prepare for it
uh yeah that's a good question um
can i break down the character
instantly from the screenplay um
generally
generally i would already have some kind
of um
natural
reaction to the script like i relate to
the character or i've just been on this
journey and
you know and then that's kind of how you
know whether you want to do the project
or not because you've felt ins you've
felt you've gone on a journey of felt
emotionally um attached to this
character and then so in which case you
kind of
you go on that
trajectory um
but not
not you can't really essentially uh do
that kind of groundwork or at least if
you do
you're an actor who's just um
you're you're just working for yourself
you know
the thing is i guess a lot of people
don't unders or have trouble with
um
is that uh acting is a process and it
work it it's a collaboration and it
really comes down with the filmmaker and
the director so um
you've got you've got to discover it
together it it might feel like it's on
page 68 and it's at this monumental
event or this moment but it might
actually come sooner when you're making
it and you just never know um
and they might just find that they want
to discover it later on in the edit so
um so you really don't have control of
uh
when you know when there's a pinnacle
you know moment in which that happens
but yeah you've got gotta feel
instinctively uh to it from the
beginning from the get-go otherwise
there is no input you can't you gotta
you gotta draw from somewhere so um yeah
yeah you've gotta feel that pull right
away when you read the script absolutely
yeah and obviously yeah i was drawn to a
lot of characters
you know who go on an arc and have a
dynamic and a journey and an obstacle
and what have you uh you know most lead
characters are going to do that anyway
a lot of characters around that don't
have that sort of arc but uh
yeah yeah you are 26 and you have two
decades 20 years of acting experience
we're gonna get into a lot of that
tonight um which is extreme it's really
extraordinary to think about when you
were six uh your first acting experience
on
it's like it's like this is your life
right uh i'm ready to retire but yeah
i'm already uh you know don't retire
there's so much more to come for me
there's so much great stuff but in
inspector calls you were six years old
right you guys you were doing it there
was a quote that you gave where you said
you were going on stage about the time
that most six-year-olds were going to
bed and then you're kind of coming home
at midnight i'm wondering when you were
doing inspector calls did you feel at
that point that that was your calling or
that in some ways your your calling had
found you
yeah i mean i don't think i could
comprehend what i was really doing at
six years old um
but the beauty of it that you know and i
have i've got kids and my daughter is
you know i've got a four-year-old and
six-year-old and um
and uh i couldn't imagine that she'd be
doing what i was doing um it's almost
like child labour i guess uh
um
what's beautiful though being being a
child and doing that is it really comes
from um from from from from deep within
a passion um there's nothing more to it
than
than
feeling
uh alive on stage and being able to just
take direction at an early age do what i
was supposed to do
and uh yeah and have the stamina and the
energy to do it every every three times
a week i think at that time and um and
then i'd
you know i lived outside of the city i
think it was it was a show in the west
end in london sorry and uh and i lived
outside the city
so i'd have a chaperone who would drive
me up we'd do the show the curtain call
would leave
and yeah i'd be back at
home by midnight school in the morning
you know like any other kid's normal
routine
um with no sort of
whisper of what i've been doing the
night before did it feel like play did
it feel like you were able to kind of go
and play at like another level as a
six-year-old
yeah i mean it was an adult world
it was a whole
experience and adventure and
um
it was exciting um i was that kind of
kid i i was very um
sociable
um
and uh
and energetic i think i always think the
the reason why i fell into this thing is
that uh the activities i did outside of
my school was
it was that my parents would have a
break because i was just like this mad
energy so they'd try and tire me out by
you know having gymnastics and martial
arts and swimming and
acting and dance and by the end of the
week you know and i'd be going up and
down for auditions and what have you and
but uh
gaining the lifestyle and and and and
what i guess my parents did was just
enable those opportunities and encourage
what i love doing and that's probably
one of the best bit of parenting that
they've ever passed on to me what i love
is that as part of your your parents
plan to get your energy out it was also
do that play that stephen daldry is
directing so there's like there's
gymnastics there's one around the doldry
play and i just love that yeah i mean
it's it's quite funny in hindsight there
was my first thing i did it was steven
dawdry and
and i reminded him when i bumped into
him about a year ago and said uh i was
that boy who opened the trap door and he
was like quite shocked and uh said
that's incredible and uh i knew we'd
have like i knew we had a connection in
some ways
so that was kind of nice yeah well you
did so much more uh british stage work
after that and british tv and movies
including
a small role in shanghai nights in which
you look at owen wilson and jackie chan
and you say i'm charlie chaplin which is
actually a terrific little moment in a
terrific film you also said that uh
that you always felt comfortable being
other people not yourself like that sort
of was a comfortable thing one of the
reasons that acting appealed to you is
you're able to kind of be somebody else
is that still part of the appeal for
acting for you oh absolutely i mean i
think um
that's the beauty in in it it's the
fantasy um
to
indulge and dive into and study you know
people and characters and uh
be able to go on
ludicrous journeys that i probably
wouldn't do in my personal life um so
yeah
and i think from an early age it was
like an escapism really you know and
therapeutic and uh
so yeah it's an interesting quote though
the idea that you're always more
confident as somebody else the uh and
then because it takes a lot of
confidence to play the young john lennon
in nowhere boy which you guys saw a clip
from um the film is so insightful about
lenin's early years what were some of
the keys to you aaron about john lennon
as you were kind of diving into him and
preparing for the role what were some of
the keys to that performance
oh um
the beauty about that that script um was
it was a standalone script it didn't
actually have need to be connected to
lenin in any way it was already powerful
and moving
it was written by
matt greenhouse and he's a phenomenal
writer
so
it was just on its own a standalone
coming of age story
about a young
man discovering
um
his mother and and and love and
adolescence and
what his position in the world was i
mean it was so um complex and dynamic
and deep and so many layers and then
added to that there was obviously it was
lennon so
but the interesting thing about it was
that
uh it was uh
probably the only part of lennon's life
that wasn't documented so
and i think it ends
at the end of the movie when they go off
to hamburg
um
and you know and then that's probably
the earliest time you can start uh in
documentaries you know
but um
so it was like my mission to uh to study
and um and and
grasp as much of uh lennon's
uh mannerisms his voice uh his humor his
anger
um he had a lot of rage and anger
obviously after his mother died and
um
so
which was difficult because then we're
working backwards because it sort of you
know was
it was it was great knowing that um
actually the funny discovery was
actually uh
the relationship that you had with yoko
later on in his life when he felt secure
and loved was actually quite
inspirational for for quite a lot of his
early childhood because i think it felt
like he found peace and and love and
and
and security
and uh so i used quite a lot of that um
to bring into his sort of childhood um
what else was important important to me
that um i learned how to play the guitar
i sang
um you didn't do either one of those
really before that i mean no i didn't i
mean i didn't you know in fact i think
you know so i i was having to learn you
know rock and roll chords and things and
and um and that was great um
um
yeah i i mean i uh so yeah it was
it was a mixture of things i mean um
yeah there's so much going on there in
fact the one of the scenes i love is
there's a scene outside of um john's
house and yourself and thomas brodie
sangster who plays paul mccartney are
outside and and paul says you know we
have to write our own lyrics and and you
as john say i write and there's so much
going on in your face at that moment
there's there's sort of pride is yeah i
write but then there's also you know
then he turns sort of turns to paul and
he says you know poems and and stories
and and he's sort of confused but also
sort of you know you know in a way sort
of in awe of the of the depth that that
is required that that he writes this
stuff and paul's talking about something
else it's a really beautiful moment and
it shows the tricky interior life that
you sort of had to show you kind of had
to telegraph what was going on in the
future but also live him in that moment
right
right yeah and i think
there was a few things kind of going on
i think there was sort of um
he uh
he was he sort of you know there was a
sensitive side obviously to lennon and i
think you know he didn't he never really
wanted to come across as like a softy or
anything you know i think it was just
sort of
he had obviously you know
would that be embarrassing if he uh if
he admitted that he wrote poetry or what
have you or yeah i mean you know and
also sort of discovering a new
friendship and a new possible i mean
there's quite a lot actually to
um you know what i love them is that
also
the uh at the time there was the effect
of you know elvis came out and the
effect that he had on women and the
effect that it had on his mum and or the
excitement of rock and roll and it was
almost like he just needed to equate the
two it's like okay so i don't know if he
really cared so much about like
okay elvis gets the attention of women i
need to be like him or it was more like
i need to be like him because he gets
the attention of my mom
you know and there was so many dynamics
like that that were really interesting
which
i mean were great for me as an actor um
i mean most of that i've you know i is
having um a
fantastic script obviously but a great
filmmaker at the helm you know and um
having someone who a director would take
me on that journey as well
who we will name now of course that film
is directed by sam taylor wood now sam
taylor johnson your wife and whom you
have a terrific family with uh something
that john lennon i'm sure the
down-to-earth romantic who also worked
with his partner in life and his uh his
soul mate would appreciate uh that film
must be so special to you for so many
reasons obviously because of sam right
yeah absolutely i think yeah it's where
i met my wife and um
but um it's probably where i was pushed
and challenged the most as as an actor
and you know and
um
with kind of preparation and focus and
you know real sort of character to get
uh to get the group to get to grips with
um
holding the weight of a name like lennon
i guess um
many kind of things
to it uh but
yeah it was um
one of the most
it's probably one of the proudest films
i've um
i've made yeah
it's a beautiful film so you were
neither a singer nor a guitar player on
that film were you a comic book kid when
you got the lead in kick ass and we
should note this if people don't know it
but for posterity that kick-ass uh in
addition to being a verb and an
adjective is also the name of your
character's alter ego in that terrific
film were you up on the culture of
comics when you uh went for the audition
for that
uh no no
um
no yeah
it's it was a world um
yeah that i i definitely wasn't uh
grasped into i mean
the irony is that i've now done quite a
few sort of comic
have you gone back to read something
have you got oh this is what they were
all talking about at 17 when i was yeah
i mean i the only i do obviously i read
them
um purely just for the
character um
yeah kick ass kick ass was interesting
because um and i think as well at the
time
uh only
maybe one um
one little issue was you know one or two
issues were out of kick ass so
um i actually read mark miller's uh
uh wanted and things like that earlier
sort of graphic novels and things to
kind of get the kind of tone of what
yeah what he's like but um
yeah it was it was interesting that was
kind of great actually to be kind of
coming out at the same time as
the comic book right right and and also
at the same time as nowhere boy has sort
of had that sort of one-two punch no pun
intended uh but there's also a lot of
insane physical stuff in there uh to
kind of you know make that leap that
must have been a revelation as well
there's a sense of here's another aspect
to acting another level to to bring you
to of
really difficult physical stuff a whole
other aspect to to acting in another
dimension right
the comic book world is that what you're
saying the genre and the whole kind of
yeah the rough housing that's the you
know the real physical stuff that's
involved in a movie like that
yeah it was it was uh
it was it was it was interesting i mean
actually
i guess for that character um
i actually physically didn't need to be
able to do
you know
uh martial arts or anything like that so
uh essentially he's
he's
he's not really your typical superhero
he's just sort of you know very um he's
a he's a comic book reader himself and
and
um
and a kid who aspires to be you know uh
his own little superhero and live out
his fantasy um it was interesting it was
really interesting for me to
um
you know i i i felt like it was probably
my first uh real american role um
i can't remember
playing american before that so it was
the first time i kind of was it you know
was gonna be seen
um in an american role and which i think
you know um which was interesting for
when it came out because i was so far
from
who had played but um
yeah uh
throw me some questions i'm not like
well that actually brings me an
interesting idea because
on screen you never really got a chance
to really kind of play a teenager kick
ass and kick ass too or sort of your
opportunities to do that you know john
lennon not being the typical teenager in
liverpool 1955 and then you pretty much
went quickly into into adult roles that
we'll talk about in a moment that's an
interesting thing that that kick-ass and
kick-ass too or your your teenager hood
on film in a way right right yeah i
guess i could i th the first one was
able to kind of jump into there a lot
easier than the second time because um a
lot had changed in in my life personally
to to then kind of go back to playing
something like that but that became the
obstacle and the challenge in a sense to
kind of
see if um i can kind of pick off pick up
where i last left and and people could
instantly
go oh nothing's changed about that guy
which was kind of a challenge in itself
um
whereas someone like say chloe had
obviously
changed physically in over that time
so um and was on on a different journey
and trajectory in
in the movie so
but yeah um
yeah it was it was great for me i mean
matthew vaughn's a great filmmaker and
um you know it was a huge opportunity to
to uh to have humor action emotion
um
yeah it was it was a whole other entity
in 2011 then you went like lightning
into a trio of dramatic films that are
all just really all terrific including
appearing opposite glenn close and mia
wasakowski and albert knobs that's an
interesting performance because in many
ways your character joe represents sort
of an emotionally stunted kind of dulled
masculinity in a film that is that where
masculinity is itself a performance it's
sort of a conceit um as you're kind of
you know approaching the role how did
you look at it in that way because
you've got obviously glenn and janet
mcteer's characters are living their
lives as men and they're women um what
was it like to kind of approach that
role
well um
i love this it's really interesting for
me by the way to kind of try and go back
and um
remember what i've uh done because i'm
it's uh
i'll see it you know we'll we'll do it
the once the premiere what have you and
then it's uh i move on um
and realistically the experiences um
is everything to me is is when i'm doing
it but um but yeah
so um yes so
there was i think i can't remember what
was the attraction originally if it was
just
being able to play a character that i've
never done before if it was more like um
the um
like i played like a scumbag sort of
irish
just kind of thief i can't really quite
remember by sort of wearing my way into
a hotel and fall in love with this girl
and uh
um
but i think it was more um
that that film just felt sometimes there
are films that come around and there are
characters that speak to you and then
sometimes there are films that are like
um
someone else's passion project it was
glenn close's real passion predator
she's been wanting to get off the ground
i think it felt more like
it felt like a team spirit like we all
you know mia mia toscas came in and
um it was sort of an ensemble of of of
actors i was just um
admired and wanted to work with
um
and there were some interesting scenes
and things like that i can't quite i
can't really indulge in what happens
because i can't remember well it was
great i'm sure it's okay it was great
i'm sure to be part of somebody's dream
like that since glenn had obviously been
been planning for so many years
then in 2012 you did uh savages directed
by the hyper-masculine oliver stone he
played the dreadlocked pot grower named
ben who with his buddy chon played by
taylor kitsch gets in hot water with a
mexican drug cartel now
ben is sort of the decent one of the
group he doesn't want to kill people he
wants to do some good he's pretty much
the only person in the movie who feels
that way uh what did you learn from from
working with oliver stone what was that
experience like oh my god i learn
everything i think from oliver um
i really truly that was uh a real game
changer in in in
in my career not maybe from an outside
perspective for me internally what i
physically and emotionally went through
on that that was
a grueling shoot it was intense
oliver stone is
an incredible filmmaker genius
and
and and it was it was it was challenging
um it wasn't an easy shoot um
but
that doesn't mean it wasn't one of the
best you know things that it it was
i like challenge i like um
controversy and i like um you know i
need i need that to kind of power power
us through
um
but someone like oliver is he's someone
who just soaks up knowledge
and um
and uh and and he uh
it's hard to keep up he speaks ten
conversations at once so
you know and if you've missed a beat
then you you just he won't go back again
um so you know you had he's got
incredible energy and
and i think that's what his films have
and they have
a darkness and they have
um
and they has they also have kind of
sensitivity to it he's quite incredible
how he does that but um
but he is someone that doesn't do things
by half so you know on that set we had
yeah i played a marijuana drug dealer so
we had a marijuana drug dealer on set
and we had
a hacker who's one of the most
intense hacker you know he's just done
snowden and he just worked on that also
we had a you know great hacker we had
dea agents we had um
we had witness protection um
people really early on we had um
i remember once i actually i remember
arriving to los angeles i've just
my wife and i just had our first uh
child and um
um actually she well she might have been
what but she might i think she turned
one when i made that movie um
and sam was pregnant with our
our
next child um
and when i arrived to los angeles you
know
we found a home that we could be
comfortable in and then he sent a
package about a folder this sort of size
that i just had um
a care package for me and i just left it
on the side for a couple days whilst we
were unpacking
and i finally got around to and this is
just in the kitchen living with mary and
i finally got around to uh
opening the first page and it was
um
it was like
disfigured like
cartel chopped off heads and
and
just
pages upon pages of like artifacts of
you know drug dealers and cartel members
and
most
hideous um
disturbing images
that i had just lying around are very
you know innocent uh pure
uh home um
but
that's kind of oliver it's not it's he
sort of bypasses that it's just indulge
yourself in the facts and the knowledge
and you know to see where we can grasp
and take it in and um
and uh and it was great having all those
people on you know and i went around and
went in and out of
drug dealers houses in los angeles and
you know
little modest homes and then would go
into their cupboard
the hat on the house on the outside
would look quite big and you go in and
go oh it's like a tardis it's really
it's really quite small like
what's this is really bizarre and i go
and then we go into that cupboard and
then to a little door and then we go
into their uv light freaking
you know weed dome of like
marijuana and then
it was quite incredible me and kids
it was the most bizarre thing you know
um
and i think you know like you sort of
take on you know these things are like
you so you take this aura of uh that
energy on and it's not always that great
you know it's like this sort of um
you know it takes a long time to shed it
after a movie but i remember um
i decided that like maybe in these
scenes i'd have dreadlocks or something
and i felt like maybe some sort of uh
tribal i come back from i think he comes
back from some part of uh africa or
something and they've been with these
tribal people and that and i was looking
at dreads or something it wasn't it
wasn't just be a rastafari thing it was
more
um a spiritual i can't remember the
tribe we were looking at anyway um
that's beside the point we got dreads
and
uh and i remember
i know we're in hollywood so we've asked
for like a flashy
um
convertible audi convertible or
something and
and and i literally looked like a drug
dealer i literally was driving around
los angeles and i remember getting
pulled over numerous times to ask for my
idea of not doing anything wrong but
with the rooftop down dreadlocks high
and i'm like you know um it just uh and
yeah i was probably 22 or something i
don't know so
um
you know it's bizarre um when i didn't
have the package from oliver in the car
at that point did you with the severed
heads
oh no i mean yeah no i was mad it was
really mad but i mean i listen part
those are just funny little stories on
the outside i mean what i learned from
it was actually um
is you know i had people around me like
uh john travolta and benicio del toro
and
phenomenal actors and
watching benicio del toro
take a scene off the page was um
was it was
it was everything i don't know it was
like just seeing just genius happen
right in front of you is uh
he he's he's incredible um
he's great intimidation scenes without
being you know without fear it's i don't
know he's he was incredible um
um
you know yeah you learn a lot from your
peers around you and and
and i i thank oliver for pushing us
through really dark heavy times um it
was an easy um but i i think he's um
he's actually quite a lovely lovely soul
you know he gets down to it he's uh
he's quite sweet then came joe wright's
extraordinary anna karenina which like
nowhere boy is a multiple bafta nominee
you play count vronsky a man both
dashing and i believe weasley might be
the word tolstoy would use uh because uh
you terrifically capture there's a
description of him in the book i always
love where he says you know one must pay
one's gambling debts but not one's
taylor which i think is sort of a
terrific maximum in life uh but you
captured this sort of both the charming
aspect of vronsky and the aloof aspect
of him what was it like playing a
character from classic
literature was it difficult um yeah no
no i mean i think and someone like
tolstoy as well i mean that's uh that
was pretty hefty hefty stuff man um
and intimidating um but um
tom stoppard wrote the screenplay
adapted the book to screenplay and and
it was just moving and so incredibly
beautiful
and
you know as much
knowledge you can get from obviously the
book and
and and
you you take that
and then
and then you really just
um work from from the script
but on top of all that obviously uh joe
wright had
um this
really artistic way of being able to um
he wanted to
kind of express emotion through
through dance and um and and and
and um so beca so it was interesting uh
and it that kind of became the kind of
uh
the intrigue and the challenge and uh
you know he had mega
um
backdrops and and sets and um
and it was very sort of indulging in in
the aesthetic and
um and
and the physicality of everything so
so it was interesting it was interesting
way of being able to and i was and and
i'm from a dance background as well so
to to to i was always
and i think
the thing the funny thing is he cast
that from from from a from a a music
video that my wife and i did for rem
berlin right
which i don't know many if you've anyone
seen that but it's uh
it's kind of a
liberating kind of piece of just sort of
of
of mad dance tourette's down um
the back streets of london and um
and it's weirdly been the only thing
that that kind of has got me a lot more
work from that than uh than anything
i've done everyone said but it's that
that thing that you did that that dance
thing is just so
so like you know
it's there's no sort of there's no
vanity to it it's just raw and it's like
open and expressive and
um but those are the sort of things i
make with my wife so
that's all i gotta find there's a
terrific moment there where you're sort
of imitating a squirrel there's an
etching of a squirrel yeah on a wall and
you're sort of dancing like a school
it's a terrific it's really a great
video and the thing is like that that
wasn't something that was it was just
there was there was a squirrel graffiti
artwork on the wall
and the moment to
take in the environment around us and
just work that's what kind of being
artistic and being act that's acting
kind of as just
improv improv improvisation
off-the-cuff instinctual
humor like it was just uh that was so
lovely to do but
joe cast me really from that
and and so
but i think um it would
it's the only time i'll be honest is the
only time i actually from i learned a
lot from doing those two films back to
back
i'll never do it again
because
i need time to
digest what i've just done
and i need time to prep the next thing
um
and uh
and then there needs to be a break in
between those two because i need to be
me and i need to live my life and and
figure out who i am again and sort of
rebalance ground myself you know um but
at the time
uh these were two great opportunities
and i took them you know
anna karenina actually and oliver stone
they came around the same time i got
offered at the same time but it just so
happened to
um go
one in front of the other but i was
literally the day
i was uh
the ending of savages or i think i'm
shot through the neck or something or
blood i'm covered in blood from my head
right down to my toes and um
and i the day i wrapped was the same day
i got on a flight flew over to london
and
and uh and was
started started shooting and i still had
blood stains all day down the back of my
leg and i'm putting on this like white
suit and i'm putting on a wig and i just
shaved the rest of this bit off and i i
was starting to grow out like a
mustache for this
and it was this weird blend so you know
tonight to play this like you know from
this sort of drug dealing like
hippie kind of role american cali dude
to
russian
you know tolstoy's count bronski and
very petite and carry it and this kind
of
um and i don't you know
it gets a lot it gets a lot of praise
and it was critically uh did really well
but
as from
my uh personal experience of of doing
that was just um it wasn't it was
relentless and it wasn't giving myself
the best quality
of uh i didn't give myself the
opportunity to do do better um
um
and and that's that you know
we mentioned comic books before with uh
with kick ass you did another one a much
more serious one in uh the blockbuster
avengers sequel age of ultron which i
actually think is a terrific movie but
your performance
in particular as uh as petro maximoff as
quicksilver there is an aspect we're
going to talk about that and godzilla
kind of combined because i think there's
an art to the blockbuster and i think
that i've said this a couple of times
about comic book movies which is that
they're like the westerns of this era
just like the westerns were in the 50s
and 60s you're gonna have high and
you're gonna have low and anything with
marvel is generally going to be on the
high end and one thing that you bring to
that character is sort of a sense that
to my eyes felt like he was like a a
refugee survivor from a from a war-torn
country like that character really has a
lot of depth and pain going on in him
how did you approach that and then we'll
kind of segue from that to to godzilla
you know i think that was just that was
joss's kind of interpretation of being
able to set it in a world that we all
know today i think you know there's
obviously that is constantly going on
and people want to
kind of turn a blind eye to uh
you know
refugees and what have you and i think
um
and it it just fit it
fit perfectly for these two characters
um and then
you know and how
they wanted to kind of pull perspective
on you know
incorporate the world in avengers and
and kind of look back and think of you
know avengers as
is america and what do we you know see
everyone's perspective so it was an it
was an interesting angle and i think
it's
trying to be edgy and controversial and
it's
smart but obviously everyone knows it's
a it's a commercial
blockbuster movie so you can only
indulge so much in politics and
everything and
and economics and i think um
um but
the interesting funny thing about um
avengers marvel it's it's it's a big
entity it's a machine it's um it's a
studio in itself and and
i always think it's really interesting
though what marvel did because
marvel as a studio only
makes
their own movies they only make their
own characters in marvel so they care
you know it's interesting most studios
can make big
big blockbuster movies but they're
they're
their main goal is to make a lot of
money and yeah i'm not saying marvel
isn't and there's a big franchise
element to it but they actually want to
make a lot more movies so they really do
care about their characters and they
care they care about how they're going
to be seen
and
so you actually got a collaborative
process instantly with the producers in
the studio and it was really quite
lovely and
um but the process starts a good year
and a half before they even start making
a movie so i was approached by joss
before i'd even started shooting
godzilla the year before so
um godzilla was a lot of fun to make i
was doing right that was like a real
that was a challenge but it was also
probably a bit of a kick was something
new for you to do
yeah no godzilla was um
well just i'll just jump back because
just what was interesting was that um
there was a a a a comic book that we
worked from for avengers um there is a
series that they they were using
and um
there were a few things that were really
important to me that that
i was able to
um
look like the character and he had white
hair
um and i wanted to sound eastern
european because he was
that's where sokovia was set it was set
somewhere in eastern europe
and um
and joss immediately said absolutely you
know i want you to do what you do and
and that's great and that's it's quite
company but um
but we'll have to screen test that and
we'll have to try those out and there's
a process and you know
and it was interesting but
and we ended up the way we wanted it to
be but it was um
but that was great and and um yeah
godzilla
godzilla just before that was
that was a big move it was a big move
for me
um
i already had i already struggled a bit
with um
with with with
with
the idea that the more i did the or if
the sort of success that comes with uh
acting like i said i started when i was
really young so it kind of came from a
pure um
feeling of just passion and love and and
and the other side of it the attention
and the
what have you comes it comes with it i
had to learn along the way and it's
something i i find uncomfortable and um
and some sometimes intrusive and what
have you and you just deal with it and
you you have to learn it um
so i kind of avoided any big movie
before that point and i know kick cast
was big but it was independently funded
right it was not studio movie
so that was that was kind of like the
first realm and it and then it and then
i i closed down a bit you know i was
like this is uh i got a bit
self-destructive and was a bit
uh
it wasn't for me and i wanted to just
stay stick on a trajectory of just
smaller movies independent films
and godzilla came around and you know
firstly i was just like this you know
like in my as if i'm going to do
godzilla and whatever that's you know
some monster movie kind of thing
and a lot i i just i thought that my my
manager told me about i just laughed and
nobody honestly what well so we got
around what else is gonna what else can
we do
um
and um
but then it was the filmmaker gareth
edwards was the real pawn and and at the
time i uh that year he just brought out
a movie um
was it called monsters right was it
called monsters
that he shot for barely anything
and um
and it was incredible as scoop
thinks the lead in that and he's
incredible and and and i and i just
remember just being so
beautifully shot and well directed and
like it was improvised it was
improvisation or was that re i can i he
i i knew that moment i was like okay
wait else
let me sit down with him and what's uh
let me hear what he has to say which is
another eye opener by the way i didn't
know
this is a really interesting
new thing i've learned you know is that
and all these jobs i've taken you know
you learn something
um
there was no script
it was a big blockbuster monster movie
but it's the filmmaker it really is it
always comes down to the filmmaker
and uh and i'm always intrigued now no
matter what you kind of got to take
these things without judgment and
criticism and
and uh you know i was too quick to be
cynical and what have you and
and the guy's a genius um i think the
guy's the sweetest loveliest
guy he's modest and humble but we
supposed to have a 30-minute meeting and
it turned into six hours of us just like
just playing apart ideas and because
there was no script so he was just like
talking about character and where i want
to take you and the j and
it was
so collaborative in this
working with him that it just felt like
i don't know it was a it was a new jump
and um and it also
i also felt for the first time
um
after taking that big breather probably
after oliver stone and joe wright's film
having a chance to uh get back to just
being me and uh with my wife and kids
and and just
grounded and and
it gave me an uh a chance to feel i felt
loved and secure i feel security and
loving my family and and i think at that
point i felt like
okay i'm i'm ready to
i'm ready to take on a lead role in the
next monster big legendary movie you
know like
um
and uh
and and uh that demanded some kind of
responsibility when you walked on set it
was different it was like i bought a
there was a different kind of role to
play um
and uh and i had a great time and it was
shot by seamus mcgarvey who by the way i
went with four times now so he did
nowhere boy
godzilla uh anna karenina and nocturnal
animals so
well speaking of nocturnal animals
because one of the things we were
talking about a couple minutes ago in
terms of genre films i think the genre
films can have a soul and ray marcus
your character in nocturnal animals
really does not have a soul which is
part of the point this beautiful film it
is so
extraordinary one of the things about it
is to my eye it's about how it's about
brutality and art
and about emotional brutality and life
and how sometimes the latter can bleed
into the former um god how did you
approach this very very dark character
and and where did you want to go with it
where did you see it going
um i don't think i approached approached
it approached me i think um tom rather
flat
flatteringly uh called
just say i'm interested in you for my
second film and and and i was instantly
thrilled and flattered and excited and
um and then when i read
the role that he thought of me i was
kind of perplexed as to why uh
wait so you want me to be a psychopath
and a rapist and a murderer
okay
all right uh a story within a story
without giving anything away there's a
story within the story of nocturnal
animals which is where aaron's character
is and it is it is there's a lot to it
yeah no it's complex now listen i i i
it
it took me
some time to um
compress uh
that that that role because it wasn't
instantly uh relatable or anything that
i've said to you so far today that you
need to connect with the character it
was the opposite and um
that's
why it became the challenge that became
the thing of like well all right well
then
then go to what i know versus is is work
with the filmmaker who what's his vision
for it how does he see this being
um and we created something that i felt
happy doing and
i actually felt more
i mean maybe i didn't really know
you never really know if things work or
not but what i felt was actually more
important than that was it was i felt
secure with with tom tom ford who
directed the movie
he
he made me feel like i just i put my
full trust in him and and i and was able
to
therefore just explore and play
the character i play
is um
not only a fictional character
but a part of a
figment of
amy adams imagination she's reading this
book within within the film called
nocturnal animals that her
ex-husband uh like his partner has sent
her
um
and
it's this violent
visceral um
metaphor for their breakup so you kind
of go back into flashbacks of
their their journey and them falling in
love with each other whilst you're
reading this horrific
um dark um
thriller set in west texas
um
whilst this you know it's it's really
intense and really poetically done i'm
really beautiful and
what tom's done is very ambitious but
it's
it's incredible um
but there was room for from my character
i saw this character in the story there
was room for my character to be very um
elaborate and um and
tom wanted someone that was very
overbearing and
magnetic and
to contrast with this very stark sterile
world that
this contemporary world that we see
susan amy adams in
and um
and my character
it wasn't just he's a villainous
character it was kind of he was this um
um very charismatic
charming um
but unpredictable
and therefore dangerous kind of uh
animal in a way
it's a very american character in so
many ways actually that mocking sort of
comical quality in some ways that bigger
than life and it sort of makes them sort
of very very american the character also
reminds me in so many ways and of
anthony hopkins in silence the lambs or
dennis hopper in blue velvet they're
sort of kind of joins the pantheon of
great movie villains without without uh
tom's uh inspirations for that role was
uh jack nicholson and the shining and um
travis beckel from taxi driver de niro
yeah just sort of
electric and like magnetic and just
[ __ ] frightening and just like
because there was just some predictive
like didn't know what they were going to
do next and he wanted that kind of
frantic energy in that kind of
kooky kind of
unsettling feeling um
you know and and that was interesting it
was by the way it's scary to do do
something like that where you're like
whoa you know i'm gonna be crazy and
kooky and wild and and um
and um you know
but you
at some point you let go and you allow
and i and why how tom
directs is that he's very specific and
precise and knows exactly what he wants
so there was room and freedom to be
improvised and play
but in that though he made boundaries
and limitations and
and so that you know it was interesting
it is an extraordinary and challenging
film people will find out when it opens
here on november 18th to wrap up aaron
you are kind of decided that you're
going to be doing one film a year really
just to kind of spend more time with
your family kind of choosing that one
film carefully how how
is your process going to be it must
become so much more um
paramount to really look at every role
as as this is going to be the one this
year how important is it going to be to
really narrow it down
yeah i mean and it's not a mad challenge
like you'd think i mean i've done it for
the last five years now i've done one
thing a year for the last five
um i think maybe from that momentous two
movies back to back and and what it
really uh didn't enable me to to
to be able to give to my uh craft and
but i think also what he was going to
touch on upon us
something about escapism um
and
and that's kind of what acting was for
me um
until
until i felt you know until until i had
a family
there was no reason to escape anymore
and so
um
for most my childhood obviously you know
i was jumping from one job to the next
and you know that was the lifestyle and
i meet these people and
then you
you move on and
and uh
and a very sort of self-destructive kind
of world but um
but i don't feel that anymore i don't
feel the ambition i don't feel like
i'm i'm i'm not doing enough and i don't
feel like i'm
i need to do more and i feel like
i don't feel
like i've got to do it for anybody else
but myself
and and that's a beautiful feeling and
i'm going to get that because i've got
such love and support in my my wife and
my family but um and i've got such a
great
and i actually enjoy being a parent
so why i don't really want to take my
time up doing um but yeah no
you you want to work with people that
you admire and love i want to work with
great filmmakers i want interesting
characters um
yeah they firstly don't come around that
often secondly
um
yeah they gotta really speak to me they
really gotta feel like it's worth
spending three months three to six
months of my year in indulging in this
and putting everyone else on hold and
and dealing with this i mean it's not
easy i just playing uh
not telling him i was playing a a a
psychopathic character i mean it's like
first three months i was you know
growing my hair out my beard and my
nails and i'm
watching and reading documentary
i'm studying characters like jeffrey
dahmer and ted bundy and watching
characters
watching documentaries on these guys
that pick up mannerisms and i'm and i'm
picking up dirty habits like smoking and
drinking because i actually want to feel
toxic from the inside out and i want to
feel like i want to look like my skin's
like sickly and pale and i want to you
know i
that's why i enjoy about the process of
acting now that's what i enjoy about and
the last where i did
with doug lyman i play a a sniper
guy and i spent you know four or five
nights on a
in arkansas on a military base with
sniper guys and
stars you know so
and i have time for that now and i have
i also spent enough time at home to feel
like i can
warrant giving myself that space and
time to try and indulge in something
artistic and creative and not feel like
i'm drawn between the two and be like uh
you know so much
so that's a nice feeling um that and i
support my wife and what she does and i
step back and
my wife's just been in wow i've been in
new york as for the last three months
my wife directed
a new uh
netflix series called gypsy with naomi
watts and
she set the whole series up and the tone
and shot the first two episodes
and uh i love and enjoy that i love just
being back at home and and with the kids
and being able to um
um
support her in her love and her joy you
know it's very empowering for me to see
her empowered and being and doing what
she loves doing and we've got girls and
i feel like they need to you know grow
up knowing that
you know their mother is um is a
is a role model to them you know they
can do
um do what they love doing and we're all
here as a family and a uni uh to support
one another it's all about the balance
of time isn't it just picking that
family time versus career time we're so
happy that you have taken the time with
us tonight
thank you very much
you